what is up operators I'd like to talk to
you about a beautiful new piece of real
estate in Rainbow six siege Tower is a
split-level gorgeous space with
amenities like outdoor vistas a museum
gift shop
and oh my god right in my freaking
eyeballs always dead
so Tower is a multi-level map where
defenders get the bottom two floors and
attackers get the roof top floor and
exterior I will never get sick of this
repel the Roman game here is real and
lots of vertical gunfights go down
between levels the interior space puts
both teams on even footing with no
traditional outside that we could find
for defenders all in all it's one of my
favorite maps in several DLCs with the
perfect mix of theme destruction size
and routes there are three new operators
with two of them having dueling
abilities on attack is dock heavy with
our logic bomb she focuses mostly on
hacking cameras and trolling defenders
her more elaborate trick is the hack
dead bodies
unlike Caviar's interrogation that
requires downed but not out opponents
when she hacks cameras it looks like
this for defenders anyone on attack can
then switch to defender camps this means
attacking teams need to start really
thinking if they want to shoot out every
camera on their way in
or use them later though cabbies other
ability is trolling defenders by maybe
the other ability is trolling defenders
by yes hello no not now mom I'm kind of
busy with murders gosh can I call you
back
oops gotta go calling all living
defender cellphones gives away their
position by Annoying ringtones Real Talk
though I saw this ability make attackers
overconfident on several occasions and
often just let the phone keep ringing
the other attacker could be considered
ash lights Zofia fires concussion and
impact grenade zat range
she seems best when staying behind the
main group in a support role since
concussion grenades are usually only
good in clothes where operators can
quickly enter a room and take advantage
of a stunned opponent covering extra
distance after using her launcher solos
probably a disadvantage she does have a
pretty sweet LMG knee though with 150
rounds plus one in the chamber we were
sent some b-roll after the event that
showed her using an ability called
withstand in which she got up from a
down state similar to doc but we didn't
actually experience this while playing
defenders get the silent type vigil his
ability renders him invisible the drones
and cameras making him the counterpoint
to dick heavy attacker drones do get a
visual cue when he's in the room jamming
them but no specific location because of
this he's a good Romer and camper I
could see him having an advantage as the
last man standing at a bomb site let's
quickly talk about guns notable are
Sophia's LMG II which has lots of
bullets and pretty darn good accuracy -
kevie MK 14 EBR DMR which is actually
crazy good from the hip but don't forget
it's semi-auto and oak abbey and vigils
over-under BOS g 12.2
that fire slugs I didn't use this one
much because don't miss the SMG and
pistol sidearms that are being added to
the game for doke abbey and vigil are
also a ton of fun and give those
operators plenty of wiggle room to take
more situational primaries so are you
new to siege or veteran if so do you
want a sequel to the game or are these
seasons doing it for you as operators
get added what abilities do you still
have a burning desire to have in the
game let's discuss in the comments below
hey you come back yeah
[Music]
yeah how do you like it in your eyeholes